juni ist der bundesrat hat die neuen
corona regeln der beschlossene jetzt
gerade und das gute das gibt es diesmal
einmal auch zu verkünden es gibt keine
extra knallhart bewohner beginn bis
schüler da ist er der jubel an der
deutschen schule hier in letzter sekunde
haben die bundesländer nämlich karl
lauterbach diese knallharte regeln noch
ausgeredet die bundesregierung gibt also
ihre geplanten coroner regeln für
schulen ja darum geht's lauterbach
wollte dass schüler und schülerinnen
nach einer corona erkrankung erst mit
einem bestätigten negativen test wieder
zum unterricht zurückkehren das ist
jetzt gestrichen es war im übrigen
vorher zum beispiel auf der arbeit
sowieso schon nicht der fall also da
ganz ganz viele haben sich beschwert
angesagt schon wieder machen wir
strengere regeln für die kinder als für
die erwachsenen das ist aber jetzt durch
meine gute nachricht unsere bildpolitik
reporterin nadja aswad bei uns im studio
also gute nachricht grüßt sich nadja
gute nachricht für alle schüler und
schülerinnen in deutschland genau so ist
es es hat in der tat einen heftigen
protest gebrauch seitens der
bundesländer bis man diese umstrittene
paragraf 34 war es im
infektionsschutzgesetz zurückgenommen
hat er fest paragraf sozusagen genauso
genauso weil du musst tatsächlich nur
nach einer so ernsten krankheit wie zb
der pest oder cholera musst du dich
gesund testen bevor du wieder am
öffentlichen leben teilnehmen kannst das
ist ja vollkommen undenkbar warum hätte
man so etwas machen sollen bei schulen
das ist ja ein rückfall in die zeit vor
der vor der impfung das ist also wer
vollkommen undenkbar gewesen insofern
gut dass das jetzt gekippt wurde dafür
zum massiven druck aus den ländern
gebraucht sogar aus den eigenen reihen
der genossen vorher war karl lauterbach
nicht eingeknickt also immerhin später
über den hierzu hat das eingesehen was
bedeutet das jetzt für die schule in
ganz konkret wie geht man da in denen
der korona herbst und winter wesentlich
entspannter als zuvor geplant dann kann
das am ersten oktober normal weitergehen
und man muss jetzt halt schauen es ist
gut dass dieser paragraf zurückgenommen
wurde ist das für die eltern auf jeden
fall eine große sorge weniger weil in
der tat wie will man denn sein kind frei
testen und gesund essen nach seiner
erkrankung die heutzutage regelmäßig
vorkommt es ist gut dass corona an der
stelle herabgestuft wird dass man dann
nicht mehr so ernst mit ins gericht geht
wie zum beispiel vor der impfung noch
mal ganz schnell für alle schüler und
schülerinnen in deutschland ja oder nein
es gibt keine oder eben doch
schulschließung dieses jahr da sind sich
die länder eigentlich dass man dagegen
ist das haben auch schon eltern und
lehrerverbände angekündigt zu klagen
falls sich so weit kommen sollte also
also neun ganz klar so wie es jetzt
aussieht nein ja beide trotzdem raten
nicht ganz einig nämlich auch so genau
so und wer vorsichtig wenn man sich
denken ja am ende findet es finden sich
eben doch dann nochmal schlupflöcher ja
ich bin aber skeptisch ich bin da eher
bei patricia wehrpflicht ja genauso ich
genauso und dann müssen wir auch also
ich gehe davon aus dass es dabei bleibt
weil das wurde ja auch genau so
angekündigt am ende des tages ist glaube
ich die patrizia sagt er ist noch sehr
viel bewegung drin und punkt drei masken
flucht ja genauso genauso und auch da
werden wir gucken welche länder welchen
weg gehen weil da ist ja jetzt gerade
noch ein wirklich großes kuddelmuddel es
ist noch gar nicht alles klar was
eigentlich konkret kommt insofern man
kann das beste hoffen wir zumindest das
ja schon mal dieser sehr umstrittene
paragraf 34 vollkommen zu recht
gestrichen wurden dass also die gute
nachricht ein wie in den tv weiter geht
ja es wird vielen herzlichen dank mit
einem besuch sehr gern
[Musik]